.
AND NOW WE ARE SEEING IT HAPPEN
HERE AS WE KNEW IT WOULD.
JULIANNE IS WITH THE WISCONSIN
FAMILY ACTION OFFICE, THE PLACE
THAT WAS JUST FIREBOMBED IN
MADISON -- SORRY, WHERE A FIRE
BROKE OUT.
I'M SORRY TO EVEN SAY THAT TO
YOU, IT'S GOT TO BE PAINFUL
SINCE IT WAS YOUR OFFICE THAT
WAS FIREBOMBED.
WHAT DO YOU MAKE OF THE COVERAGE
OF THIS, BY THE WAY.
>> THE COVERAGE HAS BEEN
AMAZING, TUCKER.
TO SEE THIS THING GO NATIONAL,
IT IS QUITE AN EXPERIENCE TO BE
HONEST.
WE ARE AN ADVOCACY GROUP, AN
EDUCATIONAL GROUP, WE DO, WHAT
THE ISSUES OF THE DAY FROM A
CHRISTIAN PERSPECTIVE.
TO BE HONEST WITH YOU, I WASN'T
SURE WHAT WOULD HAPPEN AFTER WE
HAD THIS MOLOTOV COCKTAIL THROWN
INTO HER OFFICE AND GRAFFITI
WRITTEN ON THE OUTSIDE WALLS OF
OUR BUILDING.
THE COVERAGE HAS BEEN MIXED.
I TALKED TO SOME MEDIA OUTLETS
WHERE BASICALLY THEY SAID HEY,
YOU GUYS DID THIS.
IT IS AN INSIDE JOB.
YEAH RIGHT, WE WOULD DESTROY OUR
OWN OFFICE.
LET IS CERTAINLY PATENTLY FALSE.
OVERALL, I MUST TELL YOU THAT
OTHER THAN REFERRING TO US AS AN
ANTIABORTION GROUP, WHICH WE
WOULD PREFER TO RECOGNIZE FOR
BEING PRO-LIFE, THE COVERAGE,
EVEN AT THE LOCAL LEVEL OR
NATIONAL LEVEL, HAS BEEN FAIRLY
EVENHANDED.
BECAUSE WE HAVE SUCH EVIDENCE.
I'M WALKING ON GLASS IN MY
OFFICE.
WE HAVE A MAJOR CLEANUP JOB
AHEAD OF US IN ORDER TO GET BACK
TO BUSINESS AS NORMAL.
TUCKER, MAY I SAY, YOU ARE
EXACTLY RIGHT IN YOUR MONOLOGUE.
THIS IS FUNDAMENTALLY BECAUSE WE
HOLD A CHRISTIAN WORLDVIEW I'D
ACTUALLY LIVE IT OUT.
WHEN THEY WORK IN THE
LEGISLATURE OR WHEN WE TALK
TO -- WHEN WE TAKE OUR MESSAGE
TO THE MEDIA.
THAT IS THE COURT ISSUE.
>> WELL, YEAH.
IT DOES -- NOT EVERY CHRISTIAN
LEADER, THERE'S A LOT OF LOUSY
CHRISTIAN LEADERS OUT THERE, BUT
CHRISTIAN PEOPLE ARE THE KINDEST
PEOPLE, THE MOST COMMITTED TO
HUMAN RIGHTS BY ANY GROUP.
I CAN'T THINK OF ANOTHER MORE
COMMITTED.
WHY DO YOU THINK THEY HATE YOU
SO MUCH?
>> YOU SAID IT WELL, WE STAND IN
THEIR WAY.
I'VE BEEN UP THIS FOR 25 YEARS
AND I'VE SAID IT REPEATEDLY.
WHEN THERE IS AN IMPEDIMENT OF
THE WAY OF THE LIBERAL AGENDA,
THEY HAVE TO FIND A WAY TO
SIDELINE YOU, TO SILENCE YOU.
I'VE EVEN BEEN TOLD THEIR
ULTIMATE GOAL IS TO DESTROY US.
I WOULD SAY THEY TRY THAT ON
SUNDAY MORNING.
UNDER THE CLOAK OF DARKNESS WHEN
THEY ATTACKED OUR OFFICE.
THAT WAS THE GOAL.
THEY WANT US TO GO AWAY.
THEY WANT US TO BE COWED INTO
SILENCE.
I'M TELLING YOU RIGHT NOW, THEY
PICKED THE WRONG GROUP IF THAT'S
WHAT THEY WANT, BECAUSE THIS HAS
MADE IT STRONGER, THIS IS MADE
AT BOULDER.
WE ARE NOT GOING TO GO AWAY, WE
ARE NOT GOING TO BE QUIET.
WE ARE SPEAKING TRUTH, HELPING
PEOPLE, ENCOURAGING PEOPLE TO
STAND UP, SHOW, AND SPEAK UP ON
THESE ISSUES.
THEIR AGENDA IS TRULY TO MAKE
CHRISTIANITY -- EXACTLY,
EXACTLY.
>> I THINK THAT'S RIGHT.
I HAVE SOR